あ、いたいたいたいた
よかった
お前がいないとはじまらないぜ
よし！
今年最後のちゃんとした動画かもしれない
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
私は今年中に明らかにしておきたいことが一つある
それはなにか
そう
こちらにカルピスも原液があります
皆知ってるか知らないけど
カルピスって薄めて飲む物なんだぜ
このカルピスもね原液のまま飲むと凄い苦いんですよ
5倍に薄めて15杯分
5倍に薄めなきゃいけないんです
そう
普通のコンビニに売ってるあのペットボトルのカルピスは
実はこのカルピスの原液を薄めたやつなんですよ
つまりこれが本当のカルピス
本当はね、薄めて飲むとね、これ1杯で何杯も飲めるんですよ
あんまり飲んだことないからよくわかんないですけども
ああ
原液で飲んだことあんまりないんですよね
多分凄い濃いと思うんですよ
原液のまま（だと）凄い苦いんだけども
ここに書いてある通りに一回5倍に薄めて飲んでみましょう
これぐらいかな
お水
ああ、もう色的におカルピスだわ
まさにカルピスになります
おいしい
そこで私は考えた
なぜカルピスは水で薄めるのか
他にも薄める方法はたくさんあるんじゃないかって僕は
というわけで今回は主要な飲み物を準備しました
水は普通
三ツ矢サイダー
コカコーラ
オランジーナ
ポカリスエット
おーいお茶
選ばれたのはあやた（ry
アサヒスーパードライ
後はブラックのコーヒー
はいというわけでこのメンツの中でどいつが一番カルピスと相性がいいかってことをちょっとね知りたくなったわけなんですよ
間違いなく水ではない
俺の脳みそがそう言っている
カルピス、お前にはもっとふさわしい女がいるはずだ
今宵はこのレディーの中からお前が一番好きな女を持ち帰っていい
そうだろう皆
俺なに言ってるんだ
ちょっとまずそうなやつから順番に行きたいと思います
まずはお前だ、コーヒー
いや待って逆になんかおいしいコーヒーに
これ振らなきゃ
あ、振らないでくださいって書いてある
俺これはね、逆にね砂糖と混じっておいしいなんかココアとかさ、砂糖入りのコーヒー牛乳みたいになる可能性は大きい
悪くないぞ
ではまずコーヒー×カルピス頂きます
これはねえや
ないです！
次
へっへっへ
次はビール行きたいと思います
未成年は飲んじゃだめだぞ
これはさ
これはひょっとしたらおいしい可能性があるぞ
ビールのカルピスわりみたいな
色的にはこんな感じです
なになんかジントニックシャンディ・ガフみたいなお洒落なにおいがします
では頂きます
飲みやすいぞ、うまい
え、うまいうまいうまい
俺舌おかしいのかな
ビールはあんまり好きじゃないんですけど、限りなくおいしくなっている
なにこれ
美味いです
え、待って待って、うまいぞ
びっくりするうまさなんだけど
いやそんな超うまいってわけじゃないよ、落ち着け、おれが思っているだけかもしれない
ただ僕の意見からするとめちゃくちゃおいしい、うん
凄い飲みやすい
次
次はこちら
おーいお茶
お茶はね違うと思うんですよね
これねえよ
こんな色でございます
では、頂きます
無きにしも非ず
え、なんかなにカルピスって結構万能なの？
おーいお茶とカルピス合います
配分がいいのかな？
わかんないんですけどなんだろう
リプトンだよ
もうリプトン
これ二人リプトン
おーいお茶とカルピス飲むとリプトンの味がします
ピーチティーみたいなフルーツ系のにおいになるんですよ
飲みやすいな 飲みやすいな!飲みやすいな!!
いや悪くないぞ
次、こっちもアリとなると綾鷹もいけるんじゃないでしょうか
綾鷹いきます
でも結局さ、おーいお茶とやってること同じだからさ、あんまり違いはないと思うんだよ
頂きます
選ばれたのはあやた（ry
次いきましょう
ここからはちょっとね割と甘い＋甘いなんではずれではないとおもうんですけども
ポカリスエットいってみようと思います
ちょっと待っておなかがタプタプしてきたから少なめでいくよ
かんぺー（乾杯）
コメントしづらい
次はこちらオランジーナです
これはね、また未知なる遭遇だと思いますよ
乾杯
もうちょっと上いけると思ってた
三ツ矢サイダーです
なんか安定的な味になると思う
頂きます
カルピスソーダー
コカ・コーラです
最後くらいパシッとおいしくいって欲しいものですよ
ちょっと薄汚い
乾杯
ドリンクバーの味だ
よく混ぜる感じだな
よく考えたらやったことあるや
コーラはコーラのまま飲んだ方がおいしいし、カルピスはカルピスのまま飲んだ方がおいしでした
おい
こういうなんかおいしいジュース系は別にまあどっちでもいいんですけど、お茶とビールがびっくりしました
お茶とビールとカルピスはね、この子達はなかなかおいしかったです
お腹痛い
明日は多分今年のまとめとかね、2015年のダイジェストとかまとめチックな動画になると思います
じゃあな